welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the man of
spoils and this video we're breaking
down the original script a Batman V
Superman loved it I hate it the film has
become a huge talking point in the
comic-book community since its release
the Snyder cut version of Justice League
still trends on Twitter regularly and
it's hard to deny its following even if
you don't like the movie but how did it
all begin well throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
original Batman V Superman script to
talk about what we could have got there
will be some spoilers here in regards to
the actual BBS release so if you don't
want anything ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day and with that
all the way I just want to give a huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown of the original
Batman V Superman script ok so Batman V
Superman was a film that I can remember
being talked about when I was still in
primary school it seemed to be
constantly in the planning stages at
Warner Brothers but it never really went
beyond that and at times it seemed like
we would never see the world's finest
facing off against each other
there were teases glimmers of hope and
even a poster an I am Legend that helped
to feel the fires of interest
surrounding the project but it seemed
like an agonizing wait before we finally
got it now in order to discuss the
script we have to go all the way back to
2000 when the new direction of the DC EU
was first put into production
McGhee was originally tended to direct
the first BBS movie with writers at
Warner Brothers and he worked on a
script that tied into Superman lives
that movie is a story for another video
but I'm sure as you know that film ended
up dying in development hell after it
was scrapped JJ Abrams was hired to
write a new screenplay that would ignore
Superman lives and it would reboot
Superman in a film called Superman fly
by the movie even got greenlit but McGee
stepped down from the director position
to instead go off and make Charlie's
Angels full throttle great great choice
there Wolfgang Petersen was brought in
to direct the Superman Abrams script
however this was brushed to the side
after Andrew Kevin Walker pitch
his idea for BBS Warner Brothers loved
it and the Abrams script was put on hold
while sac IVA Goldsman was brought in to
rewrite Walker's draft this script went
under the codename Asylum it's online if
you want to read it in full but you're
here so I'm guessing you don't it's a
bit of a crazy story and it's kind of
all over the place but it's a fun read
if you want to see the direction that we
could have got I would say it's
definitely more hopeful than watching
Superman gets stabbed through the chest
by doomsday but it is very weird tonally
it's sort of wreck on the Batman
direction at the time and ignored the
goofiness and camp tone of Batman and
Robin in favor of a sort of soft reboot
that can still be considered canon in
some ways if you want to draw the
connections the closest thing I can
think to compare it to is Superman
Returns which took elements of the
Christopher Reeves franchise whilst
ignoring the bits that they didn't want
like that that robot lady that still
gives me nightmares ooh the final date
for this script comes from June 21st
2002 that's the most up-to-date copy I
can find it begins in a time set roughly
between five and ten years of both
Batman and Superman crime-fighting
career the best friends and clock is
even Bruce's best man at his wedding
which we'll discuss in just a bit
after Bruce found the love of his life
he decided to quit a life of being the
Dark Knight and he's truly settled down
there's no mention of Wonder Woman or
Aquaman and at no point is that Justice
League name dropped even at the end so
we can take from this that at the point
of this movie there were very few plans
to make a fully shared universe there
are however some notable aspects of the
work that do give nods to the larger
world Barbara Gordon is now the
commissioner and the Lois Lane plays a
big part in some ways it's because she
actually divorced Clark and this made
him slightly depressed Robin and Alfred
are dead and Bruce was at his lowest
point before he met the love of his life
he does still have an AI version of
Alfred though that operates sort of
similar to Jarvis and gives him someone
to sound off against whilst he's sitting
around brooding it's also important to
bear in mind that at the time of the
script writing process 9/11 had just
happened and the world changing event
looms heavily over the work
the film actually opens with a terrorist
attack on freedom monument and Clark who
is at the Daily Planet
rushes to the scene there is an amazing
changing moment that happens down an
elevator shaft to kickstart the film and
the script really captures the Donna
feeling of the character Superman
actually manages to capture one of the
terrorists and even manages to save
their life after a mob almost beat them
to death
so how come Batman hate this guy he
doesn't even kill a terrorist well it's
actually revealed that this terrorist is
really the Joker this plays a big part
later in the script and it becomes the
reason that Batman ends up hating the
Man of Steel he should have just
attached a Gaga to his leg and made him
punished to his death often
impractically large Church in the film
we actually see a headstone that has the
name Jack Napier on it and it's clear
that this is definitely the Joker though
his appearance is slightly different it
turns out in the film that Lex Luthor
figured out that Bruce Wayne was Batman
and he decided to ruin his life in a
number of ways starting with the
terrorist attack we'll get into all that
in just a bit but the wedding is held
Clark is the best man and Bruce his
finally found happiness however on the
honeymoon night the new mrs. Wayne is
shot in the neck with a Joker toxin dot
and she dies from it Bruce blames Clark
for letting the Clown Prince of Crime
live and he states that he's going to
finally end him once and for all
probably by dropping him off an even
bigger church or something anyway even
AI Fred does the know it looks better if
you write it down even Alfred doesn't
want him to do it and Superman won't let
him go through with it which causes a
big conflict between the two it
initially seems that Superman doesn't
want him to kill the Joker because he
cares about the Joker's life but it's
revealed that this actually isn't the
case at the heart of it Superman really
cares about Batman and he knows that if
he does kill the Joker that there's no
coming back from it and that it may
finally send him off the deep end
this of course juxtaposes the Snyder
version of the character in which he was
quite happy with killing people should
the occasion call for it or should he be
dragging a car behind him that he needs
to get rid of I'm just kidding I love
your Snyder now personally I feel like
this motivation is probably
than the one that we got and though I do
love BBS I always have a problem with
the reason for the fight being sending
around clogged not telling Bruce what's
really going on
I did see people say that Bruce was
unable to hear Clark trying to reason
with him because of the thickness of his
helmet and in my mind that was canon for
a long time however you do hear bruce
reply with i understand at one point so
clearly he did have at least some way to
hear what he was saying and he way bruce
sort of goes back and forth with Supes
throughout the movie constantly trying
to kill the Joker whilst the Man of
Steel gets in his way trying to stop him
Joker actually beats Batman at one point
when he goes after him and this sends
him into an even angrier rage filled
meltdown Bruce knows how far he needs to
go to stop Joker and he goes and steal
some kryptonite just in case Superman
tries to stop him he and Superman again
and Bruce tells them that he is 100%
going to drop the Joker off the biggest
church he can find and that if Supes
gets in his way that he's going down to
Superman tells him not to do it and says
that he's going to stop him if he does
and from this point onwards it's on now
this is where the big Lex twist comes
into play and it's revealed that in
order to ruin Bruce's life Lex clone the
Joker and he also created Bruce's wife
yes there's a there's a lot of cloning
going on Lex's plan was to kill Superman
through Bruce Wayne by making him fall
in love with a woman that the Joker
would then kill he knew that Bruce would
want to get revenge and that Superman
would stop him and through this the two
would fight with Batman becoming the
victor because of kryptonite here's a
plan though just shoot Superman with a
kryptonite bullet
anyway Batman goes after the Joker once
more but Superman arrives during this
Batman cunningly decided to Don some
armor laced with kryptonite and the two
go head-to-head
there's batarangs used heat vision
grenades you name it and the two really
go back and forth when duking it out
Batman even flies the batwing into him
and it goes all out and basically it's
like a fight on injustice to Superman
manages to destroy Batman's armor
through using his freeze breath and then
Batman ends the fight by shooting a
kryptonite arrow
but man then goes head-to-head with the
Joker who reveals Lex's plan Bruce is
devastated and the Joker goes to stab
him in the back but Superman saves him
and the two go head-to-head with the
Joker and his henchmen Batman goes to
kill Joker and Superman even tells him
to do it but at the last second Batman
decides to spare him because he doesn't
want to go down the dark path that it
will lead to I would have nowhere Lex
arrives in armor in states that he's
disappointed in Batman for not killing
the Joker and Superman he does the old
if you want something done right you
have to do it yourself and then Batman
and Superman face off against him Lex
gets dropped over the side of a Ledge
along with Batman and Superman saves the
latter whilst the other seemingly
tumbles to his death his body is never
found though and at the end Batman and
Superman shake hands
Batman asks if he wants to go for a beer
and Superman says how about a soda and
the two then walk off into the sunset
which ends the film and that's the movie
there were a ton of people attached the
role of Batman including Matt Damon
Johnny Depp Colin Farrell James Franco
Jude Law and even Christian Bale who at
the same time was asked to be in Darren
Aronofsky's Batman yay 1 Josh Hartnett
was offered the role of Superman and
filming was due to start in 2003 however
Warner Brothers decided instead to
pursue solo projects which would go on
to of course be Superman Returns and
Batman Begins DC went in the direction
they did but I can't help thinking what
if overall the the script was a bit all
over the place but it was definitely a
fun read that I recommend you check out
if you have any interest in either
character I hope you enjoyed this video
and this trip down memory lane and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
so comment below and let me know you
liked our breakdown and please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out a
video on all of the hidden details that
we noticed in Batman V Superman which is
going to be linked at the end every
month in the 15th we give away free
blu-ray sand all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning the marble face
report 1 box set is leave a like and
subscribe with notifications on you want
to support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chat to us on our discord
a link below our definition whitey on
Twitter hopefully we see over there very
soon and thank you for watching till the
end this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition that you've been
the best now see you next time take care
peace
[Music]